you know we need to open ourselves to
to the record of nature the silent
witness of nature the stratigraphy of
and the and the levels of radiation
in the earth and we also need to think
in term in global and planetary terms i
mean let's be
frank about what this is about we are a
species
we are knitted to other species we want
to live the previous style of
social dynamics has been no
organizational plan at all
no global sense of anything the social
program of the last 500 years has been
plunder let's plunder
and then that's what we've been doing
but now you know we've plundered enough
and you raise yourself out of the gutter
of plunder
and say you know we've got to pull back
the problem is
we've gotten so into the plunder style
that we've lost the fine
touch unconsciousness is what is
destroying
us as a species it's a luxury
of hunter gatherers it's absolutely
faithful to thermonuclear high techies
like ourselves i mean we can't have
enrageable apes locked up inside our
brains
not when we have our fingers on
thermonuclear arsenals and that sort of
thing
we have to chill out get serious about
the human enterprise we have come this
far through unimaginable hell
i mean the people the nobility
of our ancestors what they went through
without antibiotics without penicillin
without a wall-to-wall beige
carpeting i mean it has been a long pull
over the last 150 000 million
years five times the ice
has ground south from the poles a mile
deeper more splitting and islanding
human populations and bringing
you know tremendous hardship our people
have had it very very tough i mean we
are not
strong in tooth and claw all of our
adaptations
were to preserve tiny populations
i mean the estimation is that at the
height of the neanderthal period there
were less than 40
000 individuals in europe i mean
tiny tiny human populations and against
all odds and being smart smart smart
these people brought us to this point
and now you know it's our turn
and we have it within our power
to do something they had it within their
power
only to hand on the flame of hope of
aspiration of shamanic imaginings
but it's given to us if we
play it right to actually take those
hopes
and turn it into a conflagration of
transformation
that will burn away the dross of history
and recover and reunite the various
parts of the human legacy in a way that
will give
permission for a sane and caring world
the prodigal journey into history was
for a purpose the purpose was
technological prowess the perfection of
the tool
creating impulse and at the end of
history
comes the ultimate tool the flying
saucer
the omniprogrammable macintosh the
machine which does
anything and that perfected tool
is lethal then in the theater of its
creation
it has to be carried back into archaic
nature
and we have to begin to deconstruct
dematerialize
retreat begin a
feminizing of our attitude toward
ourselves and
nature care encouragement
reflection rather than dominance
utilization destruction
you've heard this speech before this is
what all
good guys say but there's no hope for it
without psychedelics because they impel
you
to change behavior to think new thoughts
to see deeper into reality to aspire
higher
and to feel more and if we can't awaken
ourselves to those things
then it's simply not going to happen
and all the the means the tools the
gnosis the shamans they still exist at
the periphery
of this doomed civilization they still
exist to help us toward a new
understanding so i don't think there's
any reason to hang
our heads this is religion as it was
practiced
the first million years this is social
responsibility as it was practiced
the first million years and
for us to take it up is nothing more
than for us to return
to the last moment in our own
story when everything made sense
and i maintained that last moment was in
that partnership
paradise in saharan africa
now we have to go forward into the past
this is the way to create a unified
meaning to what has happened to us
because if this just ends in a toxified
and ruined planet
then you know what a comment
on the values that we hold most
dear our belief that life is for
something our belief that integrity
matters
our belief that our transmission from
generation to generation was something
that was important the
meaning of it all is in the hands of the
living
those people a hundred thousand years in
the grave
their meaning is in our hands
because the question is what shall we do
with what they have given us
[Music]
[Music]
you